it's become less about this is what i  want here are my goals i think when we  surrender  in that way  we transcend ourselves and i think when  we do that we transcend our personal  power we transcend our egos we tap into  another dimension of life when we  surrender what if we got more you know  like surrender is to really like take  the limits off of life because from the  perspective of the mind and the  personality and the ego  we're only able to see a very limited  perspective of the tapestry of life and  the possibilities of life many times  from the perspective of the ego in the  eye like what do i want is just what we  think we want based on who we think we  are  and it's limited and so sometimes we get  what we think we want we manifest what  we thought we wanted from the level of  the ego  only to be dissatisfied